well we're always trying to look at the
world and do better and improve and so
certainly from my point of view I look
at the economic crisis which is unfolded
and say okay well what's the lesson for
us in this I honestly don't subscribe to
the view that the crisis is something
which should be laid on the doorstep of
MBA programs because we've trained a lot
of the people who will lead is of the
these companies but I do think there's a
couple things that I take away from it
one is around our educational programs
but importantly the second thing is
around our research programs and you
know I think if I think if you look at
what's happened we in the academic world
have done a great job of now
reconstructing well what was it that got
us to this point obviously that is of
some value but a far greater value is if
you kind of get out ahead of the curve
so if you try to think about you know
what academia what is academia
responsibility or job in this I think
it's quite significant because if you
just arbitrarily say look at the top 25
business schools in the country and on
average they're going to have about 20
finance faculty members and so right
there you have 500 academic finance
folks whose job is to observe and think
you know that's the you know us as a
research institution our faculty spend
more of their time doing research then
they then they duty teaching so in some
sense I think academia you really has
the responsibility we are in some sense
the largest think-tank going we're not
biased to any particular point of view
and so for me the question is how can we
sort of adapt and get ourselves more
into the world of business and having
our research impact day-to-day business
activity and also I think one lesson I
take from the recent events is that we
probably need a title coordination
between schools of business and schools
of Public Policy that that would be
another
a good thing for us to be doing so so I
think for us in academia to try to move
a little bit more in the direction of
the world of practice and also finding
ways to adapt our communication style so
it's much more timely than is typical in
our in our world of refereed journal
articles to think about G we really want
to have impact on the world of practice
and this is the way we we should be
doing it you know the second part of it
this second lesson I take from the
current economic crisis is if there is
one dimension in which i think the
business model or the educational model
of most MBA programs in particular could
use some variation it's really in terms
of the contact that we have with our
students and in some sense a typical MBA
program now the average age is going to
be about 26 years old so we have you
come as a 26 year old and I think of it
this way that if we said to you was a
student look here is the intellectual
buffet of the Ross School of Business
you can eat from this buffet for 20
months anytime in the rest of your life
and you choose how much how much you
want to consume when if a student said
to you well I think I'll consume for the
next nine months and then I'll go do a
summer internship for three months and
then I'll go I'll consume for another
nine months and that will be the end of
our formal relationship for the rest of
my life breast of my professional life
we'd probably say well gee that student
wasn't as smart as we thought they were
and yet that is sort of what we impose
on people so as much as we stay
connected through reunion activities I
think what we really have to do is say
we educate if you look at people we
educated in 1980 so we educated them in
1980 when they're in their mid-20s and
that would now put them at the point
when they are the CEOs of the the major
corporations and in positions of
leadership if you look back to nineteen
eighty what do you see while the three
largest employers in the Unites
states where AT&T General Motors and
Ford the three largest employers today
our Walmart ups and McDonald's so it's a
different world from when you had your
educational experience with us to what
it is today and second and secondly I
think you just look what's happened with
information and communication technology
we were not talking much about the
influence of the internet on business
activity in 1980 so I think this idea of
us really forming a lifelong
relationship with our students we're not
just educating you when you're 26 27
years old then saying well you know I
hope you read The Economist are tuned in
big think every every once in a while to
see what's going on but to really think
that we're going to have a lifelong
relationship with you I think that goes
back to my earlier point about really
looking at stimulation for research if
we every day had to be saying to
ourselves okay our alumni are expecting
us to provide insight into what's going
on today I think it will really
stimulate a great set of research
activities so so I think those those
would be my main takeaway points that
the the research model that we have we
got to speed it up a little bit you know
if we're going to have influence on the
front end rather than just be explaining
on the back end and secondly we really
should be taking this notion of lifelong
learning as a key part of our
responsibilities to our students as an
academic institution
you